Drake has been sidelined for a lot of
the Raptors games during this year's
playoffs but the Raptors current
opponent Milwaukee Bucks have had enough
of Drake's aggressive antics so here's a
couple warrants in Game four so there
was Drake giving a brief shoulder rub
two Raptors coach Nick nurse and Drake
was having a lot of fun mocking Yanis
unto tum kaho missing a free throw the
Bucs are complaining that Drake is going
beyond being a fan of inserting himself
into the game he also trash-talk jion's
as well
yeah Yanis tweet rouses rep tweeted and
has since now deleted imagine a gig and
an athlete on VIP seats right next to
the band stands up on stage just to show
off during the entire game I think he
means show knowing cameras are on him
occasionally even massaging the singer
security and him both allow it never
seen anything as disrespectful as this
before in the press conference just of
eight bucks coke coach Mike Budenholzer
weighed in saying I don't know of any
person attending the game that isn't a
participant in the game that has access
to the court I don't know how much he's
on the court sounds like it is more than
I realized there's certainly no place
for fans or whatever exactly it is that
Drake for the runner rappers to be on
the court there's boundaries and lines
for a reason the league is generally
pretty good at being on top of stuff
like that maja that's the thing like
drink is always trash talk they're very
animated on the sidelines right man to
actually put your your hands on the
front offers coach obviously the coach
didn't care whatever
I'll tell you this is the first time
I've ever in my life of watching
professional sports that I've seen a
team lose a playoff game and blame hurt
feelings never I've never seen this
before I've never seen a team whine
about something that they should be able
to tune out as pro athletes as much as
the entire Milwaukee Bucks organization
when and I'm not even a huge Drake fan
but I love Drake right now man what if
it was reversed and there was some
celebrity at the Milwaukee game I know
we've talked but there's not a lot of
celebrities that come from likes okay
why
Steve Miller shows up right Steven
Miller was not Steven Miller Steve
Miller yeah okay what if Steve Miller
shows up in some personal he was like
was that old guy doing he's crazy and
secondly I don't think that they would
feel any different the Drake is the kind
of person doing what he's doing that of
course you would hate it I would hate it
everybody should hate it but you love it
when he's doing it for your team right
the way 2019 now everybody's looking for
a safe space because we give people safe
spaces to the point of where pro
athletes are now looking for a safe
space away from Drake Jack Nicholson and
Spike Lee have been doing this stuff for
40 years I know the trash talk is fine I
just wonder - you can't see where
Drake's feet is like wonderfully steps
over the sidelines
like I don't know like if he's actually
like staying in place like you're still
sitting on the sidelines like all I know
is that after that game the Raptors gave
Drake an $800,000 blazer to wear I think
they're okay with what he's doing well
I'm sure the Raptors okay yeah I'm sure
there's no problem there are Godwin says
Drake has to be a little tamed but that
sounds I understand saying there's
boundaries and there rules but I you're
asking me I don't set those boundaries
and I don't make those rules so until
somebody else steps in it tells Drake to
calm down I'm just loving it that
Jacqueline says Rick needs to calm down
why why does he need to calm down
Jesus says I just think it's crazy that
everybody's making big deal about this
you know he's an entertainer he's a
fantastic coach doing it it's awesome
Bareilles needs to calm down and says
basketball has gone very soft okay hold
on here we're also talking about
Milwaukee when they play the Barney
theme song when the Raptors are there
and if you remember they played Kauai
laughs over and over again every time
you missed a free throw
okay so when I'm sorry a show says I
think drink has overstepped boundaries
so thank you yeah the funny thing is I
didn't notice like so the footage of
Drake these shots that we have from the
American broadcast of the game yeah the
Canadian Network didn't show that no I'm
not showing drink that much yeah on
their broadcast but the American one is
because this is what America this is
what the NBA loves the NBA has created
this celebrity culture where they
when the big stars come and they sit and
it's the only sport where you are as a
fan that's so close that close to the
action with no sort of barricades that
you have to kind of police yourself but
spike go back and watch Spike Lee videos
man this what Drake is doing is nothing
to the NBA loves it and I'll tell you
why this is also extremely important
because the NBA does not want the
Toronto Raptors to win the championship
because ratings are already down maybe
this whips them up a little bit but a
Milwaukee Toronto Eastern final is just
about worst case scenario for the NBA
they certainly don't want the Raptors in
the finale if Drake puts eyes on screens
in America that's why they keep showing
him then it's and if that is what it
takes to get the NBA behind the Raptors
then Drake is doing exactly what they
pay Drake to do which is be that guy
that close says these athletes are being
big babies yes thank you when says some
needs to give Drake a troll mascot
caution yes baby yes he's just a giant
troll like me the next game and it's
awesome what if you goes to Milwaukee
she's go to Milwaukee for the V game see
what happens then you think they're
gonna
[Laughter]